the race to find a covid19 vaccine
that could defeat the virus and allow a
return to normal life
can't come soon enough but in the
meantime the government is doing as much
as it can
like offering free flu jabs to all over
50s
and some school children but already
there is opposition
paul a military veteran along with his
cousin karen
are part of a movement of people who are
against all vaccinations
because there's all these anti-vaxxers
now isn't it well mourinho can tell you
a little bit about how we've achieved
that what do you think
do you think you're both nuts for not
wanting the vaccination
i think i'm quite sane and i think i was
saying enough to do service in the army
for for
crown and country and i'm saying enough
now to say no
to the vaccine and no to the comment of
being a nutter
but why are you against it because i'm
healthy
i don't need to take it i just feel i
don't trust no
chemicals and all these things
the distress that feeds the
anti-vaccination movement has
already picked up a loyal following
online in may
anti-lockdown protesters gathered in
london's hyde park
testing and vaccines for coronavirus
were among their targets
it's also been backed by some big names
who dismissed the scientific evidence
world number one tennis player novak's
djokovic has spoken out against vaccines
and medical intervention
even hosting a series of tennis
tournaments and parties during the
pandemic
before he was later tested positive for
covid19
while british rapper mia tweeted in
march that she would rather die
instead of getting a vaccine
in a poll earlier this month 69 percent
of people
said they would either probably or
definitely get a covid19 vaccine
should one become available but 16
percent
said they likely wouldn't and a further
so they don't know this expert is now
calling for more to be done
to show the positive benefits of
vaccinations
20 million lives saved since the year
2000 from mises vaccine alone but one of
the major
new pandemics if you like is about
misinformation that's very prevalent
particularly on social media
and we need to work hard to address that
by getting out the message about how
the safety and effectiveness of vaccines
scientists say over 70 percent of the
population
will have to get vaccinated for it to be
successful
in limiting the spread of coronavirus
for that to happen though
more work is needed not only on the
vaccine
but also convincing some sections of
society
no phillips sky news